welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and spiderman no way homes trailer has
finally arrived giving us hungry hungry
nardos of the speculation nation our
first glimpse of the multiverse madness
prophesied to come to the mcu and while
we all now have more questions than ever
before one of the main questions that we
still need to know is what's in the box
oh what's in the box well not just
what's in the box but what even is this
box that peter parker is trying to keep
away from doctor strange anyway well
let's go on ahead and speculate my nerd
babies because i think that this cube
could actually be a soul catcher that
may actually hold the entirety of the
sony spider-verse within its mysterious
ass qb walls first let's take a look at
what this box even is because it appears
to be a greenish color cube with
hexagons in the corners of each of its
six sides with each side of the cube
having these weird looking doctor
strangey symbols on them that look very
similar to the symbols that adorn the
new york hong kong and london sanctums
and these sanctums of course protect the
planet from interdimensional dark
dimensional douche canoes like dormammu
but also within the very cube it's kind
of hard to see here but there seems to
be another cube-like shape inside of the
cube itself making this magic cube not
really a cube but more of a geometric
shape called a hypercube which is what
the tesseract is itself within the mcu
it's a hypercube now why is this
significant well if you remember back to
a past video that i did on why doctor
strange's spell failed you should
definitely watch that i highly highly
recommend it for you know getting the
maximum amount out of this video i noted
that within no way home's first trailer
we see images of that astral projection
sequence from doctor strange one an
astral projection sequence that i
hypothesized to be a trip to the very
multiverse itself by use of the six
singularity energies of the universe
with each of these weird crystal blobs
in this huge blue open-ass space being
the totality of what each universe looks
like from the perspective of another
plane i believe that these crystal
shapes in doctor strange are hypercubes
well more specifically frozen hypercubes
from a higher dimension like the fourth
dimension because guys have you ever
seen what a hypercube tesseract thingy
looks like in the fourth dimension it
looks like this weird i know and
impossible to describe as beings that
live in the third dimension but i
noticed that these universe cubes from
doctor strange could have also been
potentially teased within the first
guardians of the galaxy film
specifically through this beautiful
beautiful rainbow cube that i want so
bad and i think that this was a very
clever piece of marvel studios
foreshadowing towards what the marvel
universe actually looks like on the
multiversal level a rainbow hyper cube
with each color within the cube being
representative of the six infinity stone
energies that permeate every universe
within the multiverse but the reason why
it looks different in doctor strange as
opposed to guardians one is because
hypercubes move and behave a lot
differently when you're actually outside
of the third dimension like the dr
strange cubes move in a super weird way
with this inside cube and the outside
cube dominating it forward supremacy and
special thanks to petal and the pedal 2
card for sponsoring this video pedal is
a company that wants to help you succeed
financially and that's why the pedal 2
card is designed to help you build
credit when you apply for pedal 2 your
banking history may be used to instantly
create a cash score a measure of your
credit worthiness based on income
spending and savings and it can help you
qualify even if you've never had a
credit card before the pedal 2 visa card
has no annual fee and you'll get 1 cash
back right away on eligible purchases
and up to 1.5 cashback when you make 12
on time monthly payments and their app
makes it easy to track your spending
make on-time payments and manage
subscription spending and the pedal 2
credit limit ranges from 500 to 10 000
based on credit worthiness which can
help keep your credit utilization low a
key component to building credit see if
you're pre-approved without impacting
your credit score and it takes minutes
to apply online pedal is partnered with
web bank member fdic which issues the
card and as of today the pedal 2
variable aprs range from 12.99 to 26.99
start building your credit history go to
the link in the description box below
pedal card dot com slash new rockstars
today to find out more that's petal with
a t petal p e t a l card dot com slash
new rockstars p e t a l card dot com
slash new rockstars but anyways i'm
saying all of this to save because
doctor strange's cube is a six-sided
hypercube with six-sided hexagons in the
corner of each cube and hypercubes tend
to be known to house and represent
impossible concentrations of these six
cosmic infinity stone energies within
mcu universes and the cube only became
necessary after peter and strange
botched the memory spell opening up
tears and reality for the sinister six
to come through i'm willing to bet that
this is where doctor strange is storing
the entirety of the sony marvel
universe's energies while he's cleaning
up the mess like all the mess of all
these people leaking in through all
these new holes in reality that him and
peter made i don't know why he keeps
putting the blame on peter when he's
literally the sorcerer supreme and peter
has no knowledge of magic this is your
fault strange like doctor strange
probably originally wanted and tasked
peter parker to use this box to help him
suck up doc ock electro lizard and the
boys ghostbusters luigi's mansion style
temporarily trapping them in this
pocket-dimensional reality of all their
home realities mish-mashed together
until peter and strange can catch them
all and strange can channel all their
energies back to their respective
timelines you know to go frickin die
because
they gotta die
they gotta
and i think this is what doctor strange
is doing right before peter joins the
box and this is why i believe that this
box is covered in similar markings to
those of the earth sanctums because
these markings tend to represent mystic
protection for entities that wizards of
the earth deem super sacred and there's
nothing more sacred than an entire
universe and since there is a massive
magic shield around our planet with
these types of symbols on them these
symbols around the cube probably form a
similar form of protection spell around
that pocket universe to keep the pocket
universe safe from you know evil
magicians or your occasional spider
teenager that likes to steal because the
youths are too rambunctious this is why
i never had kids but one of the biggest
reasons why i believe this hypercube
holds a universe within it is because of
that explosion that we see happen at the
top of the statue of liberty that looks
almost exactly like the explosion from
that original botched spell and because
we do see peter barker swinging around
with the hypercube i'm willing to bet
that that huge explosion was the
hypercube housing of the sony multiverse
exploding like the cube exploded
probably by electro i don't know what
happened maybe peter tripped and fell
well he's looking at zendaya
i mean that that's probably most likely
causing cracks in reality to form after
all of that compressed multiverse energy
was suddenly released and because doctor
strange doesn't have that housing for
all of that release energy anymore
doctor strange is like well they're
coming now we don't have a box to stop
them so they're coming now if i if i
could use my hands peter i would either
use them to strangle you or give myself
a vasectomy tomorrow excuse
dammit you this use but yeah that is
basically what i think that this
mysterious cube in spider-man no way
home is it's a pocket reality of every
sony marvel universe concentrated into
one small space you know like an atom
within a nucleus and that atom bomb
might just be how the sony verse gets
integrated within the marvel cinematic
universe but what do you guys think this
box is let us know in the comments
section below but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video please
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some really weird shits
and really interesting theories i think
on my twitter but more importantly
please follow us at new rockstars
wherever we are on the internet twitter
youtube and when you do on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you get cool
shirts like this boba fett shirt and
also please hit up our discord for you
know fun conversation because we're all
always talking about some fun stuff
there so 18 plus only we're searchable
now so you can search us search for us
on discord.com anyways thank you guys so
much for watching i will see you guys
later i love you guys so so so so much
goodbye
[Music]
foreign